c'est une répète pour la parade du
carnaval jimmy jam a remporté par une
petite annonce
tu croyais que j'aurais des super
pouvoirs grimm bloc tu craches sa
voiture tout de suite cerdagne aime ton
dinosaures
[Musique]
l'éclair je m'en fous ce de madrid
vous êtes attendus monsieur et toute
urgence
nous aimerions savoir pourquoi exercices
à venir ici c'est un kidnapping ou sa
première expérience avec des
transformers les deux on va dire pendant
mille ans nous l'avons cacher
sport secrète des transformers
ici sur terre pour sauvegarder notre
avenir
vous devez libérer le passé
rassurez vous
je t'aime tu fais quoi là je meurs c'est
une balle en plastique en plastique
centimes traversé deux mondes
s'affrontent incitations vivre
[Musique]
c'est bon
vous restez
il veut pas
c'est quoi ça le truc a pas faire